my name is Nayan chanda I'm editor of
the Yale global online and we are
delighted to have in our studio and
remarkable European statesmen and a wall
statesman the president marty otha sorry
of finland priscilla t sorry has been
the president of finland from nineteen
ninety four to two thousand but his
principal achievements perhaps is the
achievement of independence of namibia
as a UN Commissioner there he negotiated
for a long time with the Republic of
South Africa and brought about
independence of the country in 1990 in
the condition of his achievement many
Namibians today named their boys and
girls even Gulf Marty present necessary
has also been a key player in resolving
peace in kosovo in Aceh in Iraq and he
is currently involved with a
organization that deals with resolving
international crisis welcome mr.
president thank you very much is good to
be here now you have received the nobel
peace prize in 2008 for your
achievements in five continents and you
have dissolved so many conflicts that
one is tempted to ask what was the
perhaps the most difficult conflict that
you have resolved of course Namibia was
perhaps the most difficult one in that
sense that it what it required a long
time I joined as an African candidate
you and in 1977 when I became UN
Commissioner for Namibian and the
following year 78 I became
representative of the secretary-general
and we only got Namibia independence in
1990 so it was a very long and difficult
period the plan was there since 1978 but
we couldn't convince South Africa to
allow you and to go in and supervise and
monitor the process that led three
defenders and there was also
international complications of course
there were because had it not been for
the US government and and then assistant
secretary of state dr. Chester Crocker
who pushed through the idea that a
negotiated the whole thing in the end
that we'd had nothing to do with the
original plan that Cuban troops would
have to leave Angola and while that was
happening South Africa would agree then
that UN could come and to our surprise I
would say even today both the Cuban
government and and and and Russians
cooperated and and it went very smoothly
they also had been there for such a long
time that they thought that this had to
now finally happen it was not like at
all that why this sort of outside idea
was broad but I i think we in trying to
solve these problems I think we have to
be innovative enough and this was a good
cooperation what international community
at its best can can do yeah I was going
to ask you what what could the less sort
of a lessons one can draw from your
experience in Namibia and elsewhere as
to what are the essential conditions for
achieving peace and what are the skills
required to do that
perhaps I i would like to start by
saying that there are very little
similarities between the problem because
every conflict is a so generous it's a
special case in many ways namibia was
the last via colonization effort and and
perhaps i would say that persist you you
have to have a group of countries that
can be determined lee thriving for
solution in Kosova for instance i had
the support of the so-called contact
room United States United Kingdom France
Germany and and Italy and Russia without
that I would have been totally lost we
met regularly with their their
representatives and and I could get
packing from them from the bikini not
that they always agreed all of them
sometimes they one of them disagreed so
that that would be the responsibility of
egg negotiator light you yes zing the
parties closer together yes and and
those who support in trying to find a
solution is absolutely right if you are
entirely alone I I have found that
second is that I would even dare to say
that from my experience at least that
it's very difficult to make peace
anywhere if you don't have US government
behind and for me it hasn't mattered
whether it's a democratic or republican
administration I have been working with
both and and have been thankful for
support and cooperation by by all the
administration is it is it because of
the military political clout then a
distress has or is it because of some
idealism it represents what would be the
main isn't I think it's know for a long
time us has been the only superpower
in the world and and but you I I would
emphasize that you need very often also
countries that are in the neighborhood
for instance the role of frontline
States in Namibian solution was vital
because we had to get them on board and
and of course the parties themselves but
very often the parties are anxious to
get a solution but but sometimes those
who are outside the negotiations and
regarded friends of one of the other
side of the of the conflict I I
sometimes blame them because I said you
shouldn't be holier than the Pope if the
parties are prepared to accept don't
come with the demands that are told
totally outrageous let them see what
they are prepared to accept and and and
so that we can make some progress the
good thing about that I had to spend so
many years onami be a question is that
we became very close friends with many
of the Africans and others who were
involved in in the whole process and
that of course helped and people learn
to know each other yeah so so it becomes
a virtuous cycle where I don't know in
thank god it did idiot and and of course
elections went well in Namibia they were
perhaps the best supervised elections in
the history of elections we can't have
that sort of exercise everywhere but I
had 8,000 people with me and then other
people came to observe the whole
exercise but that was useful now the
only many of the crisis and problems you
have resolved some have kind of slide
slid back a little bit or so gone back
on some of the issues is that is that a
reality is it happening that some now if
I think of I'd say for instance which is
a province of Indonesia
they're the free as a movement had been
fighting for 30 years to get
independence for that place I was asked
to get involved when there was new
government in Indonesia they had been
negotiating earlier with three outs a
movement for three years to get them
cessation of hostilities agreement but
it didn't last more than half a year so
they turned to me and said could you
help and the only thing they were
prepared to discuss was special laudanum
before us so I I saw the leadership of
free as a movement and told them they
happen to be living in in Sweden some of
them even had 3d citizenship by that
time they had lived there for such a
long time so I could actually speak with
some of them 3ds so I I sometimes joke
that it's interesting that you are
negotiating the fate of odd set with the
Swedes but I I was very candid with them
and I said look this is not what you
have been fighting for but I if I were
you I would at least listen what the
Indonesian government have to offer and
whether you find that these proposals
are satisfactory what does this special
autonomy me so there's nothing for you
to lose let's have a quick process in in
Finland and and if you are happy good
and well fighting ends you can go back
to it to the province and and and start
a new life where we have a clearly a
democratic framework in created in the
peace negotiations and they finally they
were hesitant but they said we are
prepared the parties and we didn't use
more than half a year there there's
another extreme if I compare it with
with Namibia right but but things I they
haven't if I can bear sorry your
question about is there sliding my
sliding back I think first of all you
have to realize that the signing of a
peace agreement is on
the beginning then the real work starts
because you have to have elections in
art see for instance we had a governor's
election and then then local
parliamentary elections they went very
well there was some hassle before and
incidents but but actual elections were
peaceful i think if i compare out
saturday to any of the other provinces
in indonesia i think that's it does
fairly well there are no more incidences
of than than in any other province but
one has to understand that it's not easy
to start creating a Democratic Society
you can build a framework in peace
negotiations but then you also have to
learn that you need certain type of
expertise when you start running big
province parliamentarians who come who
have no experience of parliamentary life
also need training support so I think
there has to be it I sometimes say that
the peacemaker is like a code father
local mother Wendy debridement and and
you have to be there at least when when
when when the kids are reaching a 15
year of age perhaps longer so I go to to
Indonesia and i'd say at least once a
year and and i have said that i hope
that we reads normalcy in this
relationship with central government and
i'd say and i also encouraged donors
both EU and other bilateral donors to
assist us so that we can get the
necessary manpower to run and you also
learn if governor ear one day would be
sitting next to me here he would
definitely agree with me that he has at
least learned that you can't only employ
your friends you have to see whether
they are capable of doing what you
expect them to do
and then you have to find other social
programs if people are need of
assistance but you have to have
competent people to help ya and to move
to another area this Jasmine Revolution
which began in Tunisia and has now
spread to most of the countries of
Middle East and North Africa has been
described by many observers as
essentially youth revolt the role of
youth in organizing this surprising says
been very critical now we have been
focusing on this issue ? change first of
all the the share of young people under
under 30 in these countries and in the
whole region middle east and north
africa and and sub-saharan africa as
well is so large and you if you look at
the unemployment figures for young
people they are much higher than in a
society in general and therefore I I
have had a pleasure of participating
since 2008 in an initiative which
started in doha qatar where a fund was
established called salah tech have its
tries to improve the employment
possibilities in Middle East and North
Africa to start with and it's also does
interview with the help of color
organization and nearly thirty-six
thousand people to find out what the
people are actually thinking in a
society so that the government knows
about that and there's a half of these
people are roughly young people young
meaning below 30 or a bit yes beloved
and and up between 15 and 30 roughly so
I I think this has been an excellent
program and I have wanted to render my
own support for that as a board member
we have for instance developed very
interesting programs in in Yemen I give
that as an example and I hope that it
can continue properly but there was a
combination of micro financing through
through a newly established bank but
then additional funding also but when
somebody started something soon they
wanted to expand and and the bank was
prepared to help so it has expanded
extremely positively so these are type
of things that can be done elsewhere as
well and if we study properly how the
economies of this country is developed
then we can also see what sort of
training needs there I in a society that
you can direct you don't simply train
people for the sake of training yeah it
looks like education has been a kind of
a cookie cutter education everybody gets
the same kind of bachelor's degree which
doesn't prepared them for really too yes
what for this 21st century economy yes
and very often that also if you if you
study abroad I have met many young
people who have said that education was
good but it was even better that I had a
chance to work few years in a place or
in the country where where I did my
degree then I was much more capable of
returning back to my country and do what
was needed to be done so what what has
prevented these regimes who are really
awash with money they have most of them
have tremendous energy resources but why
have the failed to look after the
interests of the youth I think that
that's a question we have to put to the
leaders of these societies it's it's
very sad but I think we have the
question this in developed societies as
well
in my country for instance the youth
unemployment this is far too high it's I
think when it conserves the young men
it's under under 20 but it's very high
if the unemployment normal is between
eight and nine at the moment so I mean
twenty percent unemployment among the
youth for an eye it it's around that i
sent the moment and and of course you
you have to tailor make you as i said i
think that's perhaps one of the reasons
that when I was president I went through
country I had promised in my campaign
that I visit make a trip to countryside
every month beside it over the whole six
year period even more than that and I
very often wanted to see the unemployed
or people's organizations when I
sometimes met people who had gone
through ten courses and we're still
unemployed it raised the question in my
mind that there is something wrong here
disconnect between the dealing and the
derailment now it's good to have
training as well but but but it should
then lead at least fairly soon to the
proper employment and and so this was a
kind at a problem at a planning level
that people didn't fear they'll
understand what was needed what kind of
retraining yes and and perhaps it
reflected the personal desires of people
as well what they may have to be and
that of course is a rider dilemma that
that if you have like you have been a
Democratic Society you can study
whatever you like but it does not always
guarantee you an employed right and and
that that is a dilemma and I think we
sometimes and individuals have to face
it somehow but do you need actually to
have something in mind that this will
keep me my daily bread and then I can
study as much as I like things that are
thinks I'm terribly interested in I I
don't think these are contradictory in a
sense that we don't always get
our our existence from from with from
something that we love sometimes we are
lucky yes I think we both are very lucky
that's certainly as we can then have
been able to earn our living of
something that we like to do yes
absolutely yeah and this as you
mentioned the Finland has the problem
but same thing all over Western Europe
specially I think Spain Portugal France
that perhaps a even bigger problem rehab
is the aging population because that's
where our population structure is
totally different than in developing
world where where the youth is a great
part of the population structure and
therefore Europe has to learn that that
we can't survive without immigration
yeah but this is the point thing I am
sort of unable to understand is that the
one hand you have a growing population
in other words a lot of people going to
retirement but then the young people
should be able to fill in their jobs but
why is that not happy either because the
nature of job has changed I I think both
that as well and for instance I I can
see a great demand for instance for in
the health sector in my country for
instance we are getting from Asia nurses
for instance I can tell you from my own
family when I went to see my wife after
she need was operated who was the person
who was looking after her there it's
opposed to somebody who had come from
Malaysia and and who spoke perfect
finish and and was was extremely
competently assisting my by my wife and
of course it I think we will soon face a
competition of competent people because
I very often use Canada as an example it
has two world languages English and
friends we have finished and 3ds in
country I don't think that we can we
have that is the first obstacle so we
have to nowadays it is done that before
people come they have a one year's
Finnish language training and they are
completely capable of integrating but
the whole idea that that we don't
anymore have people who can take care of
us when I I'm at that age and it doesn't
take too long yeah I'd be among those
elders who need that sort of care I
would be delighted to be taking care of
anybody who who is competent so this
closing of the immigration door or
making it very difficult how do you
explain that on the one hand there is
this need the other hand there is this
great reluctance to allow people in yes
for the simple reason that it's it
should have we should have started
talking about politicians have been
rather sign in I remember when when the
present prime minister of Greece chose
Papandreou was foreign minister he
started organizing very bravely increase
meetings on on human race because his
own country had had fair amount of
immigrants from the neighborhood and I i
went and supported him in that because
we needed that sort of open discussion
and rational discussion and and perhaps
I think Europe will my guess might be at
the moment I can't say that I'm the best
expert on the immigration issues but I I
think it will be very much in a similar
vein that we have seen Canada for
instance that he care immigration we
have to get used we have been very close
societies as well I'm I can only speak
about my own country the other Nordic
countries have much more immigrants that
we have had now they have also populist
movements all of a sudden emerging like
like in my society as well so I think we
have to get used to
also this and and we have to be doing
much much better in our society is how
to integrate and that means that people
have who come have to learn our language
for instance there was a time when when
we said that you can have your language
so please come you can have your
language your culture we leave you at
peace but then when the children went to
school they learned the language in no
time so very often the elders in the
Hindu family felt very isolated and
extremely dependent on their children
now we say you have to learn the
language because otherwise you can't
properly integrate in and I think it it
serves both sides yeah is to have a
multi cultural society you have to have
other side learn the language of the
country they are living in exactly you
can still you can still learn and answer
is your own culture exactly as it should
not be that they would you live in
ghetto know in order to be multicultural
it did good for me that I have lived in
Africa I have lived in New York by the
New York is not a bad place to get
adjusted to to multicultural life and i
must confess that I I come very
willingly to New York every time I fly
over the Atlantic yeah to move to back
to the Middle East now the issue that is
really top of the people's concerned is
the question of what's happening in
Libya and directed as we meet today
today is the time when the first sort of
support group for Libya is meeting in
Doha now how do you see the fact that
the United Nations for the first time
actually authorized a no-fly zone on a
member country what's the significance
of that there are actually two things if
I would also like to emphasize is that
when when both young and old who who
actually started for the testing and
wanted more freedoms in this
in Libya for instance this was in a
sense historic thing that happened
because it now justified that these
values are universal there earlier we
have heard enough in you and corridors
and in the halls there that these are
best in values that story's over they
are they made it them now universal
values and I think that is important I
was positively surprised that Security
Council was most capable of making this
decision it was the first implementation
of the decision of a general assembly
from 2005 the responsibility to protect
that was a hallmark decision in the
General Assembly but of course it's
never finding to the member state but
now it is binding in a sense that
Security Council all members could agree
that if there is an autocratic leader
who misbehaves visa with the citizens
then international community has a
responsibility to step in and protect
those people it's not an easy decision
but I was very pleased that that
security council could do that now let's
see can the Security Council do it in a
similar case somewhere else yeah it has
not happened on other issues but I hope
that the only way that that we can move
forward is that hope that these come
sort of standard reactions I don't they
don't have mania and everyone expects
them to behave the similar fashion in
other cases yeah the other question of
course this is also going to be tested
now is that once a decision is taken by
the Security Council to offer no-fly
zone protection to the civilians who and
how it is implemented yes and that is
now being tested like as you know that
there is some division within NATO
around how hard to proceed
in disabling the battery forces I think
perhaps wrong to say that there's a
division because if my country is not a
member of NATO but when I look at NATO
structures it can decide that yes we
participate but then every country has a
right to say do we participate in this
operation or not and and therefore it is
not necessarily a division in that sense
but they may have their resources
somewhere else at the time they don't
have any resources to contribute in this
case so but of course it's a test case
for native that I I accept and i hope
that nato succeeds because if it would
not then it would have disastrous
consequences for future yes because we
having started this and then when they
halfway through saying we are unable to
actually achieve this yeah could have a
very serious consequences yes and that
that's not good for security comes lied
yeah and so some people have said that
the action taken against Libya are maybe
valid internationally because of the UN
Security Council resolution but some
countries internal law is opposed to
this kind of action like the indicates
of the United States after sin Obama did
not seek congressional approval before
authorizing participation in this no-fly
zone operation in the light of this kind
of internal opposition or legal of
struggle what would be your advice
moving forward now first of all I I
think it is important that we know
enough both of the constraints they are
in different countries I'm aware what
the Constitution in United States demand
from whoever happens to be the president
but then others don't have that sort of
constraints but I everyone has to behave
in accordance with the laws of the land
and and try to contribute and there are
many ways of participating and
contributing so that these obstacles
perhaps can be avoided and of course it
demands then leadership in a society
from all not only from those in power
one opposition as well that if there is
a unanimous decision from because I
regard this as a unanimous in Security
Council when when five countries didn't
vote they abstained but in other words
they let the decision go through so they
participated in that sense in a positive
manner yeah and the final question is
about Turkey you are a chairman of a
commission which recommended the turkey
be admitted to the European Union and
it's so far that been a lot of
resistance from some countries and how
do you see the prospect of that actually
coming to fruition no I I have been
first of all I was still president in 99
leather path of 99 when turkey caught
when we had a EU meeting in Finland and
turkey caught the candidate status there
then there was a civic initiative in
Europe and I was asked to share the
Commission independent commission of
tech and its task was to see to it that
turkey moves with the reforms that are
required so that it qualifies for the
membership and at the same time what's
the EU members the states that they deal
fairly with them and that we have done
we have produced two reports 2004 it's
argued that now turkey has done
everything so the way that it qualifies
for the start of the negotiations it
happened 2005 2009 we came with a new
report and we were very critical with
with some of our
member states in EU because they had
brought artificial obstacles for tom
turkeys way some countries had blocked
because there are 35 chapters that have
to be gone through negotiations so we
were very critical about that and I
traveled with my colleagues to 11
capitals and argued with the political
leaders there that look you have to
treat turkey like any other country and
I think there's a recognition that it
doesn't help anybody if some governments
are talking about special relationship
with their kids that are full membership
in these person aim of these
negotiations so these issues have to be
tackled I can tell you that my
independent commission is this time it's
not going to wait for another five years
to come with the report we are going in
September the turkey and most probably
half a year thereafter within that
period we will have a new report because
things are moving so fast and and of
course if one takes the trouble and
analyzes the turkeys role in the reeds
and it has been growing there's no
question about that it's an economically
doing extremely well it has political
influence in the region and and
therefore I think it's a very important
player we should not underestimate that
but turkey needs to carry out reforms as
well it doesn't help it at all if if it
arrests 50 journalists for instance
that's that's not good at all it has to
behave differently and in some ways
turkey and Finland are almost sort of
counterparts on the Finland is member of
EU but not member of NATO and vice versa
in case of a turkey now why why is
Finland not a member of NATO I think
there's nothing preventing us playing
but I I don't think that the population
is convey
that that we need nado nado membership
because we have a partnership
arrangement with nato be our
peacekeepers are operating in NATO let
peacekeeping operations like in the
Balkans so so in reality you are
actually taking part in NATO operations
yes of course we are but provided that
they are sanctioned by the by the UN and
and that that is a case like in the
Balkan operations so in practice we are
cooperating very closely the formal
membership is not not there but it
doesn't prevent I I have been asked to
lecture in NATO sometimes and then in
their internal meetings and so on so I I
have not hidden my my my views on the
membership I have argued in Finland but
but I have a long way to go to convince
all the citizens because i think the
supporters don't cover more than thirty
percent at the moment but but my
argument is very simple that I think
every Western democracy should join all
the organizations where the others are
members I don't see any any particular
danger that force would make me say that
look city since you have to do it so
it's a very practical approach and
furthermore because beam in
organizations always that's my
experience whether you come from small
or big country it depends if you have
ideas good ideas and capacity to argue
then you should be there and don't let
the others to make decisions for you
well on that note because the necessary
thank you so much for speaking with us
thank you this pleasure to be with you
thank you